car la graine d'un arbre fruitier est une variante génétique du parent.
Donc quand on trouve une variété qu'on aime vraiment,
la manière de la propager est d'en prendre une bouture sur un arbre
et de la greffer sur un autre.
C'est quand même fou de penser
que toutes les pommes Macintosh viennent d'un seul arbre
qui a été greffé à plusieurs reprises de génération en génération.
Mais cela veut aussi dire qu'une graine ne peut pas perpétuer un arbre fruitier.
Aussi loin que je m'en souvienne, on m'a parlé de la greffe.
Mon arrière-grand-père vivait de la greffe des pêchers
dans le sud-est de la Pennsylvanie.
Je ne l'ai jamais rencontré,
mais à chaque fois que quelqu'un parlait de lui,
on finissait par dire
qu'il savait si bien greffer qu'on aurait cru à un pouvoir magique, surnaturel.
J'ai choisi le nombre 40 pour cet arbre,
on le retrouve dans les religions occidentales,
c'est plus que les doigts des mains, sans dépasser l'imagination,
c'est un nombre indénombrable.
C'est une abondance ou une multitude.
Mais le problème quand j'ai commencé,
c'est que je n'arrivais pas à trouver 40 variétés de fruits à noyaux,
bien que je vive dans l'État de New York,
qui, il y a un siècle,
était l'un des principaux États producteurs de ces fruits.
Alors que certains détruisaient des vergers expérimentaux
ou très anciens,
je récupérais des branches
et je les greffais sur les arbres de ma pépinière.
Voici ce à quoi ressemblait l'Arbre quand on l'a planté au départ
et le voilà six ans plus tard.
Ce n'est clairement pas un sport à récompense immédiate.
(Rires)
Il faut un an pour savoir si une greffe a pris,
deux à trois ans pour savoir si elle produira des fruits,
et huit ans pour créer un seul arbre.
Chacune des variétés greffées sur l'Arbre aux 40 Fruits
a une forme et une couleur qui lui sont propres.
J'ai découvert qu'en jouant avec les dates de floraison
des unes par rapport aux autres,
je peux à peu près choisir à quoi ressemblera l'arbre au printemps.
Voici son apparence en été.
Il produit des fruits entre juin et septembre.
D'abord viennent les cerises, puis les abricots,
les prunes asiatiques, les nectarines et les pêches,
et je crois que j'en oublie un, quelque part…
(Rires)
Bien que ce soit une œuvre d'art exposée en dehors d'une galerie,
pendant que le projet perdure,
on préserve ces plantes grâce au monde artistique.
Comme on me demande d'en créer à différents endroits,
je vais chercher des variétés indigènes
ou qui ont été cultivées autrefois dans la région.
Je vais les prendre sur place et je les greffe sur l'arbre,
pour qu'il représente l'histoire agraire de la région où il est planté.
Puis le projet a été repéré sur Internet,
ce qui m'a horrifié et m'a rendu humble.
La chose horrible a été de voir tous les tatouages
inspirés des photos de l'Arbre.
(Rires)
Genre : « Qui voudrait faire ça à son propre corps ? »
L'humilité est venue en voyant toutes les requêtes que j'ai reçues
de pasteurs, de rabbins et de prêtres
qui souhaitaient utiliser l'Arbre pour leur office.
Puis c'est devenu un mème –
et la réponse à cette question est « Je n'espère pas. »
[Votre mariage ressemble à l'Arbre aux 40 Fruits ?]
(Rires)
Comme tous les bons mèmes,
cela m'a mené à une interview sur NPR dans l'émission « Weekend Edition »,
et en tant que professeur à l'université, je croyais que ce serait...
en quelque sorte l'apogée de ma carrière,
mais on ne sait jamais qui écoute NPR.
Quelques semaines après l'interview,
j'ai reçu un courriel du Ministère de la Défense.
La DARPA m'invitait
à venir parler d'innovation et de créativité,
mais la conversation a rapidement dévié vers la sécurité alimentaire.
Évidemment, notre sécurité nationale dépend de notre sécurité alimentaire.
Comme nous avons créé ces monocultures
qui ne font pousser que quelques variétés de chaque espèce,
si quelque chose arrive à une seule de ces variétés,
l'impact peut être énorme sur l'approvisionnement en nourriture.
La clef pour garantir notre sécurité alimentaire
est de préserver la biodiversité.
Il y a un siècle, c'était le cas grâce à tous ceux qui avaient un jardin
ou un bosquet dans leur arrière-cour
et faisaient pousser des variétés dont leur famille héritait.
Il y a des prunes qui poussent une seule semaine en août sur un seul Arbre.
Après quelques années de ce projet,
on m'a dit que j'avais une des plus grandes collections de fruits
de la côte Est des États-Unis,
ce qui, pour un artiste, est absolument terrifiant.
(Rires)
Mais je ne savais pas ce que je possédais.
J'ai découvert que la majorité des variétés
étaient un riche héritage.
Notamment celles d'avant 1945,
période des débuts de l'industrialisation de l'agriculture.
Certaines de ces variétés remontent à des milliers d'années.
En découvrant à quel point elles étaient anciennes,
je suis devenu obsédé par leur conservation
et l'art est devenu la solution.
Je suis allé dans de vieux vergers avant qu'ils ne soient rasés,
et j'ai sauvé la section de tronc
sur laquelle se trouvait le greffon originel.
J'ai commencé à mettre dans des buvards des fleurs et des feuilles
pour créer des herbiers.
J'ai commencé à séquencer de l'ADN.
Mais finalement, j'ai décidé de préserver leurs histoires
grâce à ces cadres en laiton et des descriptions typographiées.
Pour raconter l'histoire de la pêche George IV,
qui a pris racine entre deux immeubles à New York –
quelqu'un est passé devant, l'a goûtée,
et c'est devenu un succès commercial au XIXe siècle,
grâce à son si bon goût.
Puis elle a disparu
parce qu'elle voyage mal
et ne rentre pas dans les normes de l'agriculture moderne.
Mais j'ai compris que cette histoire devait être racontée.
Et dans cette narration,
il fallait inclure l'expérience du toucher,
de l'odorat et du goût.
J'ai donc décidé de créer un verger
pour rendre ces variétés accessibles au public,
et de le placer dans la zone la plus densément peuplée
que je pouvais trouver.
Bien sûr, j'ai commencé à chercher un coin de terre à New York –
(Rires)
ce qui, avec le recul, semblait plutôt ambitieux,
et sans doute la raison pour laquelle personne ne répondait à mes appels –
(Rires)
jusqu'à ce que, quatre ans plus tard, je reçoive un appel de Governors Island.
Il s'agit d'une ancienne base navale,
qui fut donnée à la ville de New York en 2000.
Et ils nous ont confié ce terrain,
situé à juste cinq minutes de New York en ferry.
Ils m'ont invité à créer un projet qu'on a appelé le « Verger ouvert »
pour rapporter des variétés de fruits
qui n'avaient plus été cultivées à New York depuis plus d'un siècle.
Le projet est en cours,
mais le Verger ouvert aura 50 arbres multi-greffés
qui porteront 200 variétés anciennes de fruits.
Ce sont des variétés qui proviennent de la région ou qui y poussaient jadis.
Des variétés comme la pomme Early Strawberry
qui provient d'un arbre au croisement de la 13e Rue et de la 3e Avenue.
Comme on ne peut pas préserver les arbres par leurs graines,
le Verger ouvert sera comme une banque génétique vivante,
une archive de ces fruits.
Comme l'Arbre aux 40 fruits,
ce sera une expérience sensorielle
et symbolique en même temps.
Mais surtout, elle invitera les gens à participer à la préservation des plantes
et à mieux connaître leur nourriture.
Grâce à l'Arbre aux 40 fruits,
j'ai reçu des milliers de courriels de gens
qui posaient des questions simples, comme « Comment planter un arbre ? »
Avec moins de 3% de la population
ayant un rapport direct à l'agriculture,
le Verger ouvert invitera les gens
à prendre part à la programmation et à participer à des ateliers
pour apprendre à greffer, à cultiver, à tailler un arbre et à cueillir,
à participer à des visites de dégustation et de découverte,
à travailler avec des chefs pour savoir utiliser ces fruits
et recréer des plats centenaires
pour lesquels on cultivait spécifiquement ces fruits.
Au-delà du site physique du verger,
un livre de recettes sera publié pour les regrouper toutes.
Ce sera un guide pratique
qui présentera les caractéristiques de ces fruits,
leurs origines et leur histoire.
En grandissant dans une ferme, je croyais avoir compris l'agriculture
et je ne voulais surtout pas y avoir affaire.
Je suis donc devenu artiste –
(Rires)
mais je dois reconnaître que c'est dans mon ADN.
Et je ne pense pas être le seul.
Il y a un siècle, nous étions tous beaucoup plus proches des plantes,
de la production et de l'histoire de notre nourriture,
et nous nous en sommes éloignés.
Le Verger ouvert ne donne pas seulement l'occasion
de nous reconnecter à ce passé inconnu,
mais aussi de reconsidérer le futur de notre alimentation.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)